welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and black panther we're kind of
forever opened with a send-off to
t'challa but a funeral flaked by the
heroes whom t'challa always fought
alongside allowing them to drop Thanos
into his kingdom and kill his countrymen
before Thanos staffed an additional half
of those survivors allowing Captain
America to keep Bucky on ice and
supplying Bucky with a new vibranium arm
and being the freaking first out of a
portal on caps left during the Battle of
birth and Avengers endgame so why did
none of the Avengers attend to chala's
funeral well of course the real reason
is this is a movie and movies cost money
and unlike Tony Stark's funeral and
Avengers end game not every MCU hero is
on the call sheet for wakanda forever if
they were to pay Ruffalo and Hemsworth
and Mackie Stan Cumberbatch Renner and
the rest to make a cameo they'd have to
I don't know light talocon even less
than they did but this is the MCU where
every logical inconsistency has an
in-universe explanation scram too much
not now but there may actually be a very
valid reason why the Avengers did not
attend to chalo's funeral in wakanda
forever and I gotta tell you this answer
May bum you out even more but it is
worth considering that many of the
Avengers aren't exactly around to attend
something like this right now Tony and
Natasha obviously dead Steve is a on the
moon we don't really know Thor is on
another planet with Gore's daughter
stopping Beach fights Bruce Banner is
either on sakar if what kind of forever
is set during She-Hulk or just dealing
with the sun's Scar and you know that
guy looks like a handful the Guardians
are off world it didn't really have a
ton of time with t'challa Dr Strange is
in the dark dimension Wanda is either
dead or in another realm Peter Parker is
Just a Nobody in New York probably
without a passport so that really just
leaves Roadie Sam Bucky white Vision
Wong Scott hope and Clint we bought
alongside the Chala in endgame and past
films and were no shows at his funeral I
mean I don't know maybe Bucky is still
reeling from his arm and didn't want to
return to wakanda empty shouldered
admitting that he lost some valuable
vibranium but what's perhaps more
Curious is that someone like Everett
Ross also failed to appear at the
funeral given that he does appear in
this movie elsewhere and he had a long
time friendship with wakandans from that
2018 film a simple explanation could
just be that what kind London Royal
funerals are sacred ceremonial Affairs
in which only wakandans are invited and
other friends and loved ones of t'challa
like Nakia and toussainted held separate
Memorial Services outside of wakanda I
mean let's be honest it was already a
little weird to see Everett Ross and
Bucky wearing wakandan Garb and I don't
think we needed to see them with Clint
Barton and Scott Lang and like Hulk
wearing white robes dancing alongside
the others in the funeral March this is
supposed to be a somber Affair 2023 is
just around the corner and I want to hit
the ground running away from my loved
ones who I made Church memories with
this holiday season if you want to get
away You're gonna need some money to
fuel your flight and there's no better
way to save up for a little me time than
by using upside upside is a free app
that lets you earn cashback on everyday
purchases like gas groceries or dinner
it's easy to use and it works for me
upside is essential for buying gas when
my Tank's on empty I open the upside app
I search for a nearby gas station
offering a good deal I claim it and then
I head over there to buy some gas I can
check in or snap a pic of the receipt
and I I am good to go no special cards
to carry or numbers to remember just
upsides app on my phone anytime I want I
can cash out to my bank account PayPal
or an e-gift card for Amazon another
Brands upside users are earning more
than a million dollars every week and it
has a 4.8 star rating on the app store
to get started download the free upside
app and use the code new rockstars to
get five dollars or more cash back on
your first purchase of 10 or more but we
should also take a step back to realize
that funerals are truly not for the
deceased they're for the mourners so
when we look at to Charles funeral and
who was or wasn't there it's less a
statement of t'challa and his
relationships as a reflection of ramonda
and shuri in their relationships we
don't know how Ramona I'm sure he felt
about the Avengers but it is noteworthy
that ramonda closes off wakanda from the
outside world in her appearance at the
U.N a reversal of t'challa's open-armed
policy now ramonda is completely
justified in doing this the Americans in
the French had begun attacking wakanda
Outreach centers and designing detectors
to plunder vibranium and by the way
where were the adventures in those
instances huh what do we ask that
question and the Avengers
they went home what Avengers you muck up
one mission in Nigeria and now when
Molly Gets Hit you're like
oh I didn't have things covered but it's
also just valid for remote exchange
course from t'challa's International
Outreach policy to a more defensive
posture because let's be real what did
Open Arms get Ramona as she powerfully
stated in this film she was Queen of the
most powerful nation in the world and
her entire family is gone had she not
given everything t'challa died from an
illness that is never identified in this
film but according to shuri it was
something from which t'challa suffered
in silence without shuri and others
finding out about it until it was too
late the film of course avoids focusing
too much on how t'challa died to stay
away from the perception that they might
be exploiting Chadwick boseman's death
as a plot point or a fictionalized
spectacle of any kind and instead
smartly keeps things focused on shuri as
an instrument of grief and how the
living should best process losing a
loved one but by the lines suffered in
Silence the implication certainly is
that t'challa might have had a somewhat
concealable disease similar to the colon
cancer that Bozeman himself suffered
from for several years and if so
t'challa would be one of many characters
in the MCU who died from cancer in
recent years Jane Foster Maria Rambo
Meredith quill James cancer was implied
to be an incidental bit of bad fortune
Maria Rambo's cancer was left as a
mystery but Meredith Quill's cancer was
a deliberate Act of Murder By an ego The
Living Planet who admitted to giving
Meredith her brain tumor and that moment
in Guardians Volume 2 confirmed it
celestials have at least the ability to
manifest tumors in people's brains
perhaps through Celestial light AKA
Cosmic radiation so it's worth
considering that in the MCU exposure to
Cosmic radiation like this like Jane
Foster with The Ether Maria Rambo
through the Tesseract derived Cosmic
radiation that Carol Danvers carries
with her and the exposure to Infinity
Stones seen by people in the near
vicinity of the battle of Earth in the
Battle of wakanda may have just left
some unlucky individuals with a form of
cancer now either that or just people
like Ramona suspect that exposing her
son to Cosmic battles like thanos's
Power Stone Wallop in the Battle of
wakanda where Tony Stark I am Iron Man
in the whole Battlefield and end game
might have been among the causes that
left her otherwise seemingly healthy son
with whatever his illness was and yeah
it makes sense that she would Harbor
some resentment toward the Avengers
enough to deny them an invitation to
travel's funeral like I don't know what
happened but my son was fine until he's
starting to get mixed up with all of you
look folks losing a loved one is
complicated there's no right way to
grieve and funerals don't always bring
the living together in Perfect Harmony
sometimes resentments come up between
factions of the deceased survivors about
how much of the deceased life they
occupied whether they were good for them
this is coming from someone who has a
big complicated family I can tell you
unfortunately a lot of the family
funerals I've been to have had a couple
arguments break out and if you are
watching this video and you've lost
people in your life and you've seen that
like I have you know exactly what I'm
talking about but if you're younger and
you haven't gone through that just know
that for some families when someone dies
it can be better for some loved ones if
not all family and all friends stand in
formation by like a Lakeside and instead
just pay respects in their own ways so
there you go kind of a bun where to
answer and hopefully if you came out of
what kind of forever curious where the
Avengers were this video gave you a more
sobering understanding of how funerals
often play out in the real world
sometimes it's just better to keep
things as family events and that alone
can be the most meaningful tribute
follow me on Tick Tock Hive Instagram
and Twitter at eavos follow the new
Rockstar subscribe to new Rockstar for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]